are you the type of voice actor that
watches
the anime that they were in after it
like finishes and airs and everything to
like
look back on yeah to kind of learn from
yep because i cannot do that
really like i hate hearing myself in
voice acting roles
because i get kind of second-hand
embarrassment from him being like
because
i always i'm so harsh on myself all the
time so when i hear myself on like a
game or an anime i'm always like i could
have done that line like
10 times better i know how you feel it's
like that's good though right like yeah
you know that you could improve yeah
yeah yeah it's good but it's also like
when people tell me being like oh i
heard you in the game then i'd be like
i don't know how i say on him i can't
even like talk about the role that i was
here yeah because i just don't know how
it turned out right because but there's
a lot of like big anime voice actors
that are like that as well
yeah yeah it's like i'm i mean like
hearing your own voice
after it's like because like you record
it and it's like several months after
you record it so obviously
like several months after yo you're kind
of like you've like brushed up on your
acting a little bit more than
you know what you had before so like
hearing it again it's like
oh like i didn't say that line properly
and like you know
i'm really strict on myself as well so
it's kind of like you know i look
like but then you know like it i think
it's really
important to like kind of look back yeah
yeah i think the thing that everyone
always
says the most when they try and start
voice acting is like they hit their own
voice and they can't stand it yeah
you have to like i've been i mean
personally i just think that if you
learn to like be able to listen to your
voice and not just
recoil and disgust you can then start
breaking it down and being like okay i
didn't do this that well right
you can start really focusing on that
isn't it weird that i'm okay with
hearing my own voice in
it's just youtube videos because you've
heard it so many times when you're
acting you're
you're trying to do something like
you're trying to perform right yeah
you're doing youtube it's just you yeah
yeah i'm being me i'm being an issue
i mean like i i feel though in in a lot
of my roles like because i'm not
trained or anything like that right i
just do it because i like it yeah and
i'm given the opportunity but like the
pop team epic one for instance yeah i
i played i played a new york mate
i cannot do a new york accent yeah so a
dead ass if you watch
like the actual episode that aired it's
like the most aussie sounding [ __ ]
new yorker
it is it is mayor of new york i just
love the idea that you did the take and
the director was like it's perfect yeah
yeah you're like uh no please please
please yeah i did it i did the first
take
just thinking like you know we're gonna
kind of get like a gauge of like
how not good my new york accent is and i
actually gave up halfway
i tried to do like an american accent
but at that point especially i was like
my new york or my american accent is not
that good where like i can confidently
act like i can try and speak it casually
right but
acting in another accent it's a
completely different set of skills yeah
so i was like i'm just gonna like subtly
turn it off like just turn the gauge
down as it as the recording goes on
so by the end of it i was just like yeah
new york
it's like the most australian sound in
new york yeah i was i remember seeing
that and i was just like i feel like
he's about to drop the c-bomb
you know when when's it coming no but it
was so funny because like i thought for
sure
you know i would get some pointers being
like all right uh you started off good
but you kind of depleted near the end
let's do another take all yeah let's try
that land again or something like that
fully expecting it
the director was like all right you're
good yeah but they don't
speak english right no oh so he thought
he thought i was like perfect new york
rex and it's like yeah that's that's
what all people from new york sounds
like i don't blame him
there's no way he'd know right yeah
exactly but then in japan it's like um
you know when you when you go to
recordings it's like
uh when you talk in english it's like
they expect you to speak in an american
accent but
you know because i'm from australia too
so it's like yeah
you never practice your american accent
when you're practicing well yeah like
i'm practicing now but it's still really
hard to like
i don't know like pronounce all these
american english goes
everything against australia yeah yeah i
know
i mean i can't do american we have to
like contort our faces
frustrated australian english like the
tongue is like towards the
front of the mouth yeah the american
english it's like flattering in the back
and that's like really hard to do when
you're british because you're like why
do i have to
force my tongue down you just sound like
you're kind of drowning half the time
yeah
i i
i mean i'm much better at it now since
then because i practiced but
i mean i still couldn't confidently do
like an american english
role but i feel like i don't know just
from like watching
anime recently where like we are
starting to get more like english
speaking roles done by actual like
native people yeah yeah
i feel like i've noticed like i think
finally
anime directors and producers are like
different accents
in english exist in japanese dubs or in
japanese dubs
yeah but even in the english dubs as
well because like a lot of the english
dubs are also overseen by like the
original directors and producers
so it's like i feel like they're finally
starting to realize like oh we can't
just get anyone who can speak
moderately good english like if we need
an american role
we need to get an american speaking
person yeah